In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 11 on which we commemorate our righteous
mother Theodora of Alexandria, on the 11th of the month we celebrate the memory of our Holy
Mother Theodora of Alexandria, which is most evidently true of the ten holy women renowned
in the Church for having led the ascetic life disguised in monasteries of men.
Saint Theodora, who lived in Alexandria in the reign of Emperor Zino in the years 474 through
491, is one of these women.
She was married to a devout and respectable man called Bavnotheos, but one day, led on by
the devil, she committed adultery.
No sooner had she sinned than she was so afflicted in conscience that she dared not to return
home, but felt a burning desire to do penance without delay.
So, dressing as a man and calling herself Theodore, she asked to be admitted as a novice
in a neighboring monastery.
The abbot, supposing her to be a unic and seeing how eager she was to set out on the path
of repentance straight away accepted her and clothed her in the angelic habit.
For the space of two years, Saint Theodora showed an ardent zeal in the performance of every
ascetic labor, doing the most menial tasks and spending the nights in tears and fervent
prayers to the Lord to forgive her sin and to restore in her the grace of chastity.
Her manner of life edified the brethren but greatly angered the devil who saw his pray
escaping him, but this wolfish enemy of the good would not acknowledge himself defeated
and he made use of some jealous monks to put it about that the youthful Theodore had
committed fornication with a woman of a nearby village.
They even brought his reputed child to the gate of the monastery.
Theodore was silent before her accusers.
She did not want to reveal her true identity and took what happened as a chastisement
willed by God.
She was expelled from the monastery for seven years and took the child with her as if it
were her own.
She settled in a little hut not far off where in extreme poverty she endured summer heat
and winter cold and many fold temptations of devils until at the completion of her years
of exclusion she was allowed to rejoin the brethren.
Upon her return, far from resting from her labors Theodore increased her vigils, fasts
and prayers, showing an obedience and long suffering even greater than before.
She brought the child with her, teaching him how to acquire the holy evangelical virtues
and unceasing prayers so that he truly became her son according to the Spirit.
When he had given him a final word of admonishment, she fell asleep in peace.
At that moment the abbot saw in a vision a woman clothed in shining raiment taken up into
the air to join the choir of the righteous and of the saints.
Then they all wept as they realized how far they had been mistaken in her and glorified
God who had wrought so great a wonder for living disguised among men and surpassing them
in her ascetic labors.
She was healed of carnal passion through struggling directly against fleshly temptations so that
while still clothed in the body she attained the passionlessness and purity of the angels.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.